this skincare routine might be too
bougie or have the wrong kind of like
flour in it I'll make my skin break out
I'm a little scared of trying something
new and I'm messing up my skin Zee Rosie
Rosie uh zero I'm gonna try zero waste
skincare routine good morning
are you ready to show me your tune I'm
out of bed let's do this what I love
about my teen is a ritual of it it's
like a self-care self-love moment for
myself the first thing I do I look at my
cheese and I'm like oh you're pretty is
my sense of self you're like a lot of
techniques here I use my pH when you
describe yes
I've been a star for years that's all my
skin relaxing way to start the morning
usually what are you reading right now
the top telling lies we tell ourselves
and how to stop living you usually my
strength after you take your mouth [ __ ]
uh actually martial arts before I put on
my foundation okay so I'm going to think
about your routine and see what steps we
could swap to more serious options and
then you can see if there something you
like and are sustainable for you okay
yeah
[Music]
my routine is two steps I use the space
soap bar and jojoba oil as moisturizer
that I read there were bulk but I wanted
to get some help to create Joyce's
routine hi I'm dr. Jessica Wu and I'm a
dermatologist re asked me to help her
create a zero-waste skincare plan for
Joyce
I'm grabbing firms you're a skin care at
this store called note oxlife dr. Wu and
I are outside Joyce's house and her not
to surprise her she does so Joyce I'm
going to show you how you can streamline
your routine and use up less packaging
and at the same time help you get better
looking skin without having to use as
many products I need this dr. you have
beautiful skin so a lot of what you're
doing has worked you know all those
trends about having no longer in
carotene I was like okay let me buckle
down and get my skin right sometimes
those trends about washing them several
times and using lots of products are
meant to get you to buy more products
this is like therapy overly moisturizing
or overly stripping your skin can aid
you
this is organic food grade coconut oil
works so well as a makeup remover though
natural oils help to break down the oils
in makeup even long-lasting makeup or
waterproof makeup and then you take one
of these zero waste
reusable cotton rounds and you use these
to wipe off the makeup and then you wash
and I recommend for your skin these
wonderful facial cleansing bars
I think the Onix would be really
wonderful for you because it's got
charcoal help unclog those pores and
then you take one of these bamboo
washcloths you do this and then you can
wash your face with it instead of using
all of those products and serums and
oils just find one oil that contains a
lot of different ingredients this one
contains argan oil chemical extract and
also hemp seed extract to help brighten
your skin and keep it supple and then
lastly instead of using your 365 sheet
masks I've got this wonderful facial tea
and you're gonna use this to create your
own facial steam you take a spoonful of
this take a towel make a tent over your
head and just inhale the chamomile and
help comb angry skin and breakouts being
less wasteful doesn't mean that you have
to give up pampering
well good luck Joyce give me a progress
report okay all right bye
[Music]
well let's feel nice just wipe it up oh
it's going on though you should see the
search area somebody's skin carotenes
I'll be taking less space in the
medicine cabinet
what are you minimizing are you cutting
out I'm going ten steps so for what yeah
my skin just feeling the same still dry
in some areas but pretty good I'm about
to do my chamomile tea thing I put some
skinny hot water in there definitely
more of a spa treatment now it's just
looks something I think I could do every
single day I really like them my skin is
still getting the same moisturization
with half the product so that's been
dope I really like this because it takes
to makeup off really usually no matter
how much makeup I click on my face this
stuff isn't magic ever since I started
using this light my skin has gotten so
joint even these soaps this one is my
favorite I honestly think my skin is
getting way more clear way more elzear's
in routine takes no time out on
traveling it was just so nice to have a
10-minute routine it was I was gonna
sleeper I've been going to zero waste
skincare for a minute now
actually it's blowing washing that
happens really easy and you know lest I
should take out I really like them I
actually think everyone should get
cosmetic cloths at first I was a little
mad that we took my whole system way but
I love it
you love it like look like again my skin
is a nester anymore I was over washing
my skin so that would mean more products
ambitious product cycle consumer market
consumerism yeah so how did we do on
time and money I think in the future
I'll be saving money because I'll be
buying less products and I will also not
be paying for wipes what about time I
would she went from 30 minutes to about
10 Wow thank you so much for watching
please comment below and tell us how you
reduce waste in your skincare routine
I'm still gonna use all those products
cuz it really be 0s empties it but I
think I'll ease them and
[Music]
[Applause]